so last week little baby went online and
he posted a photo of him with the watch
that he had and he was flexing on the
gram saying that he had an exclusive
40th anniversary watched by patel
philippe yeah
and it turns out that it was fake a lot
of people zoomed in on his watch because
a few people who were really into
watches wanted to see what it looked
like and they noticed that there were
some discrepancies in
like the sizing of the chain links and
different things like that and so
he little baby didn't know that it was
fake he then said that he bought it from
a reseller that he works with very
closely that sells him a lot of his
jewelry
and that reseller
apologized saying that oh i should have
personally listened to this career
suicide for that that's the watch that
was the watch yeah
i have a question and he paid four
hundred thousand for it four hundred
thousand because he couldn't get on the
exclusiveness of the actual brand got it
so that's why he went through a reseller
uh now um
foreign oh my gosh and uh
little babies big especially with the
young uh yeah he's huge so huge now you
and i know about this you gotta make 800
000. okay now so you got to make 800
grand i don't give a [ __ ] who you are
that's a lot of money it's a lot of
money that's a lot of money
you know some people with money
and they don't you're going to spend
that much money it was like i saw this
boxer who was famous kind of famous but
he had a blue phantom rolls royce how
much of those [ __ ] 500 yeah so he had to
make a million dollars the first thing
he did was million dollars when bought a
rolls royce
this kind of stuff is to me is so hard
to understand yeah when you're walking
around and you've got a million dollars
of jewelry on your body that you know if
you tried to resell you would you would
get a hundred grand for not the fatigue
if it's real watches
what about the change though right
chains are a bad idea because it's all
custom yes
chains rings and stuff they'll sell it
to you too they'll let you go bro the
reason the custom jewelry in nightmares
oh yeah i hear if you do those uh do do
your watch up or something like that but
that like
ruins the value is the value but if it's
like if he just leaves the petite
philippe alone and the other stuff yeah
yeah
oh yeah especially rolex there's a huge
industry in that yeah so it is a good
yeah so watches really hold their
goodbyes he's not doing that no no he
bought a fake one well there you go that
that stuff to me is
nuts
and you paid 400 000. like i get that
you love jewelry but bro yeah you got so
much money on your hands and that that
you
it's a depreciating asset yeah let's
just put it that way
it might be a better idea to
spend your money on some other stuff how
much money do you have in the bank
you know brian yeah he's huge but it's
yeah it's tough man it says 5 million in
the bank there you go
now that's not a lot of money man it's
not when you're spending
400 grand on a watch that's going to
last you three months
what are you driving but if you have
five million in the bank and you spent
basically damn near 800 grand on a watch
that's
you know i i had a long conversation
with a guy really like he was uh about
twenty percent of you he was no longer
let's just put it that way was a wu-tang
club yeah
and
he was telling me about how much money
he was spending
and then he told me
i said how many kids do you have
and he goes
he goes i live the lifestyle now i like
this dude talented smart guy
but he has a lot of kids because you
went like he went like that i got him he
goes i got so much all over he goes like
that
that's going to take all your money no
way to go bankrupt and then then he was
talking about having a cut back on you
know what he was
but the
people set themselves up to a point
where just to maintain what you have is
[ __ ] interesting
is a million dollars a year
more but also chin if you look at a
little baby's background like let's look
if you went to his uh
so let's just little baby was born in
atlanta in 1994 raised by a single
mother he didn't take to school dropped
out ninth grade so ninth grade education
after he was released from jail in 2017
for dealing drugs being a full-time
rapper the rest is history now he has an
impressive 5 million in the bank so you
realize from his perspective where he
comes from they're not he's probably
like i'm yeah
everybody has to and i i could have used
the people around i'm terrible with
money so i can talk you know like
financial fitness is really important
now i have a brother-in-law and dad and
a grandfather who are like hey [ __ ]
you are an idiot with money and i am i
don't pay attention i don't think about
it but
i always feel kind of like in a bit of
an affinity because if i didn't have
that guidance i'd be right there
probably yeah most people so yeah so so
unless you've been taught like how money
works you don't know you just like [ __ ]
this man i'll make more but also if
someone you feel guilty
if also if someone who doesn't come from
his background is like hey dude you
might have another three years doing
this and then who knows man you got to
come up with hit after hit it's
exhausting let's say you have an off
year what are you going to do you ever
think about that